I have so much to update you on I
actually tried to put makeup on today
for like the first time in like two
weeks this is wild wild hello I went to
the hospital everything's fine now I'm
feeling a lot a lot better now first and
foro I'm doing really well right now so
that's good also just a update the coal
capping that I've been doing for each
chemo treatment seems to be really
really working I've only had like very
minimal hair shedding I've just been
letting my hair air dry I've been
washing it very minimally and obviously
it's just kind of doing its own thing
but very cool the cold capping is
working I didn't know what kind of
expectations to have for it so that's
awesome last I talked to you guys I had
just done my chemo round three and chemo
round three itself was a success
everything that happened after Kemo
round three not so successful let me
walk you through what's been going on
and I I wrote some stuff down because my
chemo brain like they say you get chemo
fog brain and like you really can't
remember anything and like I really
can't remember anything so it's kind of
a perfect time for me to make content on
the internet cuz if you say anything bad
about me I won't remember and also you
can't say anything bad about me because
I have breast cancer let's see I don't
even know how to begin to tell this
story I've cried a lot about this story
and I'm in a much better place about it
now so I can talk about it with smile on
my face don't think I haven't processed
and won't continue to process the trauma
of what has gone down I I'm doing that
part of processing is I think talking it
out so let's talk it out so after chemo
things were fine in that I started to
feel bad which is normal they say the
what 5 to 10 days after your chemo
session are like the worst started that
downhill decline into predictable bad
then things started to get more bad my
stomach was just killing me I was having
diarrhea constantly all day long all
night long I was feeling nauseous even
after taking anti-nausea medicine my
entire stomach just felt like it was
like rotting from the inside which is a
very specific feeling to just sort of
walk around with what feels like an
intestinal graveyard that's good that's
good that's a good thing those are good
things for me to do for my body I
started to just feel like something was
wrong like this was more than just chemo
side effects I was super fatigued and
dizzy everything seemed disgusting to me
I couldn't eat like anything other than
a crackers everything was just passing
through me almost immediately on Monday
I went to my surgical doctor for an
appointment to get an ultrasound on this
fun friend and I threw up in the
bathroom of the doctor office that was
the bad news the good news is that at
that appointment the tumor in my left
breast has shrunk dramatically that's
amazing I'm so excited about that so all
she could see on the ultrasound was the
clip that was put in initially during my
first biopsy they put Clips in so that
you can find the tumor again um when
you're looking at it through Imaging
devices there seem to be no tumor just
clip and that's incredible my doctors
and I get to have now some conversation
about what's going to happen next I felt
like a corpse going to that appointment
I could barely get my body there when we
were leaving I had to run to the
bathroom and puke which was a new
development in the side effects I hadn't
been throwing up at all I'd been so
happy about not puking you know and I
started puking and that made me sad
tried to sleep at all Tuesday woke up
felt worse so my doctor scheduled at
home hydration for me on Wednesday
Wednesday thinking that maybe this was
just dehydration also Tuesday night I
started to run a fever and I was running
fevers between like 99 and 104 we have
all these different thermometers and
they all seem to read differently have
you guys noticed that we have not
figured out how to get a universally
sound thermometer while using these
thermometer guns they are so
inconsistent finally got an old school
just mouth thermometer Tuesday night oh
I felt awful myself some potatoes to try
and just put put something in my body I
threw up the potatoes I love potatoes to
throw them up was just so disheartening
then cut to Wednesday a nurse comes to
our house to do hydration I'm like
laying on the couch half awake half
asleep like my eyes just want to close
and I'm trying to keep them open out of
respect for this woman but she comes in
and the way she looked at me she looked
at me like she was looking at a dead
body I don't think expected to walk into
a patient in that condition she took my
blood pressure and it was so low she
looked at me and was like I don't know
how you're conscious right now and I was
like I don't know either I feel like I
am in some in between State of
Consciousness and unconsciousness right
now I am in a very uncomfortable lional
Universe right now she gave me hydration
but she also was like I can't in good
conscience leave you in this sort of
condition so she helped us craft an
email to my oncologist about her worries
that I had like septic shock or some
sort of infection and then my doctor of
course immediately was like go to the ER
the last thing I wanted to do was pick
up my frail
smeagle body and take it to a hospital
with a lot of people around but I knew I
had to go to the hospital I don't think
I've ever been that scared about my
health ever so we go to the ER
everybody's favorite place we park in
the hospital parking lot and we can't
find the entrance so we walk what feels
like 5 miles and Elliot's like weakened
at buring me to this entrance on these
busy streets with all these cars going
by I have sunglasses on I had two pairs
of sweatpants on because I had such a
chill in my body I couldn't get it out
and also I was having so much diarrhea I
figured if I sh through one pair of
pants I already had a spare they
immediately take us back thank God and
they put me in a room they switch me to
a gown I'm freezing cold now so they
like pile like eight different blankets
on me they run tests and realize that I
am critically depleted in like
everything calcium magnesium
sodium uh pottassium I don't know why I
said it like potassium but I had no
tassium and I was just so scared the
whole time I've never felt not to be
dramatic I felt like I was like dying
like I felt like I was in the room but I
was in a different place and then they
asked me to give them a urine sample so
I like hobble hobble to the bathroom
with a cup get the cup pee in the cup
give them back the cup and then they
tell me that they need a stool sample
but only if I can they know that I am in
a condition that is unwell they don't
want to pressure me to try and do
something that's difficult for a healthy
person to do but when I heard that I
knew like I have to give them this stool
sample I had been having diarrhea so
much and I knew that the answer to what
was wrong with me was in the diarrhea
and so I knew I had to give them some
diarrhea and I wasn't going to leave
that hospital until I did I have never
given a stool sample in my entire life I
had already at this point planned on
doing an at home stool sample retrieval
to give to my doctor before getting so
sick that I had to go to the ER so it
was already on my radar that I was going
to be making a donation of feal I just
didn't real realized that it was going
to be now and I was going to have to do
it in this busy emergency room but I
thought you're strong hell you're
fighting breast cancer and you're
fighting really well and this is part of
the battle you can do this you give them
that and I was determined so my first
attempt we're just in a side room on the
emergency room floor so it's filled with
desks and people Milling around cops
EMTs everyone's coming in and out
hanging out and everyone's having a lot
of just like casual conversation while
handling very serious stuff it is a wild
dichotomy of just like chill fun party
time and like weoo weoo weoo
like emergency like they were shooting
with each other and then turning around
and telling me that I need to shoot them
some so that they can run some tests
I've been shoot constantly it comes out
of me just like a waterfall I'm sorry
for the disgusting inness of this video
but you guys wanted updates on my health
journey and this is the update first
attempt I say I'm going to try and she
gives me a cup again just a cup a little
Dixie cup and I think well that's quite
a small Target isn't it but we can do it
I'm in a Delirious State I have half
dead person confidence I'm not going to
die without giving them some diarrhea so
let's do this I hobble I'm trying to
keep the back of my gown closed which
just like isn't working I hobble past
some cops I still have like cords tied
onto my fingers from the EKG machine
that I'm hooked up to I get to the
bathroom I sit on the toilet and I put
the cup down and stuff's coming out of
both holes and the Cup's filling up with
urine more than it's filling up with the
other stuff I'm thinking okay maybe if
it's just like a combo of the two they
have scientific strainers or something
they have tools for this they must have
tools getting all over like my fingers I
can't see anything cuz the Gown is like
covering my crotch cords that I'm
getting wet strings from the Gown are
now falling into the toilet water just
like a mess it's a mess it's a mess it's
a mess there's liquids everywhere the
cup on the ground and I stand up to try
and wash my hands off and clean myself
up and I don't know what it was about
the thrust of standing up from sitting
down but suddenly as I stood up I
started so I rush back to sit back down
and I grab the cup that's overrun with
liquids already and I try to dump some
out and I'm trying to catch what seems
to be falling out of my body
uncontrollably and I can't do it and
there's more liquids and the cords are
getting everywhere and I finally just
stop and I put it on the ground and I
look at myself and I'm just I've become
an animal I've become a half dead animal
I get up and I wash my hands and I clean
my own feces off of the floor
work I clean up as best as I can I try
to dry off the EKG machine things so
they don't know that that got wet in
this entire process I've been clanking
around in there and this bathroom is
like in the middle of the busy ER room
and finally I come out trying to keep my
gown closed again because decency I care
about at this point sort of and I hobble
over and I like put the cup down I say I
hope you can use that I think it's got a
little bit of both in there and the way
this nurse looked at me she looked at me
like she knew there was a struggle that
went down in there even though I waged a
war with myself in there I didn't win
cuz they can't use this sample it's
contaminated with urine and in my mind
I'm just like do you guys not have like
a little like the way the fish tank has
the little like you guys not have a
science one of those and so she's
looking at me like devastated like she
knows that I tried to a degree that was
degrading looking at me like she's so
sorry for my loss I lost so much of my
own dignity in that room and I'm just
like disappointed in myself devastated
with the experience this demon inside of
me is going to win just because I
couldn't get in a cup and I got back
under the blankets and I was so
disappointed in myself and I looked over
at Elliot and he had been looking at me
like he knew something terrible happened
in there the nurse left the room and I
just looked at him and I said the floor
and he started cracking up and honestly
it was so nice to laugh for like a
second and what was a very traumatic
experience unfolding I lay back on the
bed I put the blankets back on top of me
they hooked me back up to the IV into
the EKG machine and I just sat there and
I thought I'm going to do it again I'm
not going to let the diarrhea win all my
life I've let the diarrhea win I'm not
going to going to let the diarrhea win
this time and then suddenly I was
sitting on that table and I was like
whoa I got to go again here it comes and
I asked the woman if she could unhook me
again so I could run to the bathroom
because stuff's coming and she unhooked
me and then she came running around the
corner with another little cup that she
handed to me almost in like slow motion
and it's like we're in some uplifting
Sports film where I'm about to go to the
big competition but oh my God I forgot
my shoes here she comes with my Cup
shoes get the cup and I slam the door of
the bathroom ass fully out EMT cops just
hanging out sipping coffee getting a
good look at my diarrhea stained ass and
I shut the door of that bathroom and I
sit on the toilet and I connect God damn
it I connect with that cup We Are One me
and the cup and this filthy filthy demon
that's squirting out for me and I slam
the cup on the ground and I get up and I
wash my hands again I try to dry the EKG
machine cord and I come out of the
bathroom and I'm still letting my ass
hang out because at this point it's like
a Victory lap I put the cup on the
counter and I'm like I did it and they
were like oh my God that's fantastic
they were proud of me and I was proud of
me I was so proud of myself we were in
that room for about 4 hours because they
were preparing a room for us upstairs
because we were going to stay overnight
they were running tests and the results
wouldn't be ready till the next day and
also there were so many IVs that I still
needed to get pumped into my body so
after about 4 hours the room upstairs
was ready and so they transported us
upstairs and oh my God it was like
looking at a luxury suite two bedrooms
there was a private bathroom a nurse was
preparing everything it was clean I felt
like I just got like upgraded on a Delta
flight to first class and as they're
Wheeling me into the bed in this new
room the new nurse that I now have who's
with us upstairs looks at me and she
goes oh I put a bowl on the toilet so I
can collect a stool sample for you
whenever you're ready and I said what
and there was just a perfectly placed
Bowl in this perfectly private bathroom
for my imperfect poop to go and I
couldn't believe it a perfect diarrhea
collecting setup just sitting there
waiting after I've just crawled around
and my own on the bathroom floor
downstairs oh I was like oh I gave them
a sample downstairs and she was like oh
I didn't know that that's great okay
then we don't need this and I was like
but but but I'm but I'm going to still
use I'm going to still do this just in
case they can't use the sample
downstairs cuz now I'm panicked that
like I didn't do the sample downstairs
correctly so I just immediately walk
into that bathroom perfectly into this
perfectly placed Bowl handsfree and then
went back and sat on the bed just for
for fun she ended up dumping it out and
throwing the bowl away and didn't need
it but wow was it so easy oh so at that
point they gave me a bunch more IVs
throughout the night Elliot ran home at
some point and got me new underwear and
pants and came back and that was nice
and then I found out the next day that I
have something called sea diff which I
now know as SE diff when all the doctors
were saying it to me because they were
all wearing masks I thought they were
saying Seck I was like where I have
something called SE diff which is
basically a bacterial infection and wow
I was so relieved to find out that I had
a bacterial infection why was I so happy
because the thought of what I was
experiencing being just like standard
side effects of chemo I was like I can't
continue I'll die I can't continue
through the rest of the treatments that
I still have like this is killing me I'm
losing weight weight like crazy cannot
eat anything like this can't be how
people just get through chemo this is
impossible and so to find out that I
have SEI a bacterial infection that can
be treated with an antibiotic was like
we can continue with a regularly
scheduled cancer killing it sucks and it
is also contagious so everyone that was
in my room had to wear PPE Elliot and I
have had to be very conscious about our
shared space we have Clorox wipes in
both bathrooms we were wiping everything
down it's like we have our own mini
pandemic happening in our little bubble
there is a light at the end of this
tunnel I take antibiotics for 10 days
and hopefully the situation gets
rectified but man that was a really
really scary experience but you know
what they say what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger the more times you
try and catch your own diarrhea in a
tiny Dixie cup
the more self-actualized you become you
have to dehumanize yourself a little bit
to become a better human being I I've
learned in this process I've done that
you know with this chemo fog brain like
I said I really forget everything so
quickly but I don't know that I'm going
to forget the image of myself crawling
around on the ER bathroom floor with my
underwear at my ankles cleaning up my
own feces that's an image that will be
burned into my mind I got released from
the hospital the next day I got my
antibiotics I've been taking them and
I'm feeling a lot better now thank God I
am like night and day to what I was this
week I'm getting an MRI and a mammogram
so I can get some better images of where
the tumor is at or not at then talk to
my doctor about where we go from there I
have chemo round four scheduled next
Wednesday for now very optimistic about
things going well KN going what been
through it been through it a little bit
this last week been pretty quiet on the
old social medias because been handling
some business and now you know that's
kind of the breast cancer update you
never know turns out what's going to
happen next and for everyone else right
now that's going through chemo wow I got
your back I see you this is so hard
except my is so loose we're persevering
and we're still trying to find moments
of Joy moments of Peace moments of even
dare I say fun that's the update for now
I will see you guys the next time I turn
on a camera I have to go take my
medicine and possibly
[Music]
a